President Trump and his family arrived
as Palm Beach Resort last night where
they'll spend the next few days mr.
Trump leaves many in Washington puzzled
about some of the remarks he made
recently that contradict the facts
including claims about the border wall
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president Errol good morning good
morning with a fresh round of bipartisan
negotiations having just begun President
Trump says he has no confidence that a
compromise will be found before the
deadline which is now fewer than two
weeks away in which case the president
says he is likely to declare a national
emergency
something members of both parties oppose
the chant now should be finished the
wall as opposed to build the wall
because we're building a lot of wall in
a meeting at the White House on human
trafficking Friday President Trump
claimed that for the past six months
construction of a border wall has been
underway because Democrats who says
we'll never give him the money to build
it we're spending a lot of money than we
have on hand it's like in a business but
we have money on hand and we're building
in reality no new wall structures have
been built at the southern border but
renovations of existing fencing in need
of repair has taken place there's not
going to be any war money in the
legislation under the leadership of
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi Democrats are
holding firm refusing to fulfill the
president's 5.7 billion dollar demand to
build a border barrier face the nation's
Margaret Brennan asked the president
about negotiating with Speaker Pelosi in
an exclusive interview airing on Sunday
you had quite the showdown with Speaker
Pelosi what did you learn about
negotiating with her well I think that
she was very rigid which I would expect
but I think she is very bad for our
country
she knows that you need a barrier she
knows that we need border security she
wanted to win a political point I happen
to think it's very bad politics because
basically she wants open borders she
doesn't mind human trafficking or she
wouldn't do this we can reach a
bipartisan agreement under government
secure
country borders on Wednesday a
bipartisan congressional committee began
talks to reach a security and funding
deal before February 15th to avoid
another government shutdown the
president called those efforts a waste
of time and refused to rule out
declaring a national emergency we will
be looking at a national emergency
because I don't think anything's gonna
happen I think the Democrats don't want
border security following those remarks
speaker Pelosi's office released a
statement saying the president is
effectively undermining the efforts of
the bipartisan committee saying in part
his quote wild and predictable
misrepresentations do nothing to make
the country safer now we will hear more
from President Trump on this topic
Tuesday when he delivers his State of
the Union address Michelle that is right
Errol thank you